antes de profundizar en la mecánica de
cómo se dividen las células pienso que
podría ser útil hablar un poco acerca de
una gran parte del vocabulario
relacionado con el adn hay muchas
palabras algunas de ellas suenan muy
similar entre sí y pueden llegar a ser
muy confusas las primeras palabras
acerca de las cuales quisiera hablar se
refieren ya sea a como el adn genera más
adn hace copias de sí mismo o como hace
proteínas
hemos hablado acerca de esto en el vídeo
sobre adn digamos que tengo una pequeña
sección de adn tengo una a una g
una de digamos que tengo 23 y luego
tengo 2 es esto es solo una pequeña
sección y continúa hacia acá y por
supuesto es una doble hélice y tiene sus
pares de bases nitrogenadas
correspondientes entonces corresponde a
t
que con su té con at&t con a se congele
y se congele y continúe en esta
dirección y en esta dirección así que
hay unos cuantos procesos diferentes que
este adn tiene que llevar a cabo uno es
por ejemplo cuando necesitas hacer más
versiones de tus células epiteliales que
son las células de tu piel tu adn tiene
que copiarse a sí mismo y este proceso
es llamado replicación se está
replicando el adn y cómo puede este adn
copiarse a sí mismo y esta es una de las
cosas más bellas acerca de la estructura
del adn simplificando mucho esto la idea
es que estas dos hebras se separan y eso
no ocurre por sí misma este proceso es
facilitado por un montón de proteínas y
enzimas pero hablaré acerca de todos
estos detalles de microbiología en un
vídeo futuro así que estas cebras
se separan
una de la otra
se separan una de la otra
y una vez que se han separado una de la
otra que puede pasar
teníamos esta doble hélice donde todas
estas bases nitrogenadas estaban
conectadas y ahora se separan la una de
la otra una vez que se han separado que
puede hacer cada una de estas cada una
puede ahora volverse una plantilla de la
otra entonces y ahora esta hebra está
aquí sola de repente una timina puede
venir y unirse aquí y así los
nucleótidos empezarán a unirse aquí
entonces ahora habrá una timina una
citosina una adenina una adenina una
guanina una guanina y seguirá
y a esta otra hebra verde que estaba
inicialmente unida a esta hebra azul le
sucederá lo mismo tienes una adenina una
guanina timina timina citosina y
citosina entonces que acaba de suceder
mediante la separación de las hebras y
la atracción de sus bases
complementarias duplicamos esta molécula
y lo veremos a detalle en el futuro esto
es sólo para darte una idea así es como
el adn hace copias de sí mismo y
especialmente cuando hablamos de mitosis
y meiosis podríamos simplemente decir
que esta es la etapa donde ocurre la
replicación ahora la otra cosa de la
cual seguramente has oído hablar y de la
que hablé en el vídeo acerca de adn es
la transcripción
tran
que sean
en el vídeo sobre adn no me enfoque
mucho en como el adn se duplica a sí
mismo pero una de las cosas más bellas
acerca de este diseño de doble hélice es
que hace que sea realmente fácil para el
adn duplicarse a sí misma
solamente separan las dos hebras las dos
hélices y entonces ellas se vuelven una
plantilla para la otra y así se obtiene
un duplicado ahora bien la transcripción
es lo que se necesita que ocurra para
que este adn luego se transforme en
proteínas pero la transcripción es el
paso intermedio aquí se pasa de adn y
arn mensajero y entonces ese mensajero
deja el núcleo de la célula y va a los
ribosomas y hablaré de eso en un momento
más esta doble hélice una vez más se
separa durante la transcripción
así que aquí está una hebra y solo voy a
poner una hebra para que sea más
sencillo de entender digamos que vamos a
transcribir solo la hebra verde ahora en
vez de tener nucleótidos de ácido
desoxirribonucleico emparejándose con la
hebra de adn
tenemos ácido ribonucleico o adn
emparejándose con esta hebra y haré la
rn en color rosa
entonces el arnés se emparejará con esta
hebra así que la timina en el lado del
adn se emparejará con adenina guanina y
cuando hablamos de arn en vez de timina
tenemos un asilo brasil o citosina
citosina y sigue hacia acá este es arné
m
ahora este mensajero se separa y deja el
núcleo se va en el núcleo y entonces
ocurre la traducción
tras tu
sean
si recuerdas el vídeo acerca de adn
hablamos del arn de transferencia el
arnés de transferencia era una especie
de camión que llevaba a los aminoácidos
al mensajero y esto ocurre dentro de
estas partes de las células llamadas
ribosomas
la traducción es esencialmente ir del a
rn m
a las proteínas
proteínas
y vimos cómo esto sucede el a r n m se
separan
y deja el núcleo y entonces viene el arn
que son como pequeños camiones que
llevan a los aminoácidos digamos que
aquí tengo un poco de arnet tenemos
adenina guanina y guanina este es arné
de transferencia
este es un codón un cordón son tres
pares de bases y unido a este está un
aminoácido
y por acá tenemos alguna otra pieza de
arnet este es un asilo citosina y
adenina y unido a este hay un aminoácido
diferente y así los aminoácidos se unen
entre sí y forman esta larga cadena de
aminoácidos que es una proteína y las
proteínas forman estas extrañas y
complicadas estructuras
entonces solo para asegurarnos de que
todo esto quedó bien claro
si tenemos adn
y estamos haciendo copias de adn
esto se llama replicación
re
click
canción
estamos aplicando el adn ahora bien si
tenemos adn y creamos a fnm utilizando
al adn como plantilla para crear el arn
m esto se llama transcripción
esta mostra escribiendo la información
de una forma a otra ahora cuando el rn
me deja el núcleo de la célula
permítanme dibujar una célula y veremos
la estructura de la célula da detalle en
el futuro aquí tenemos el núcleo es aquí
donde todo el adn se encuentra y donde
ocurre la replicación y la transcripción
entonces el arn me deja el núcleo y se
va a los ribosomas de los cuales
hablaremos más en el futuro y entonces
ocurre la traducción y se forman las
proteínas entonces cuando pasamos de rn
m a proteínas se le llama traducción
atrás
tu visión estamos traduciendo del código
genético al código de proteínas por
decirlo así así que estos son diferentes
términos y los estoy escribiendo aquí
para asegurarnos de que estos conceptos
queden bien claros y de que utilicen las
palabras correctas cuando estés hablando
acerca de estos diferentes procesos
ahora la otra parte del vocabulario
relacionado con el adn la cual cuando la
estudie por primera vez me pareció muy
confusa son las palabras cromosoma
cromatina y cromatina les escribiré aquí
abajo
cromosoma
creo
tina
y creo
nativa
un cromosoma y ya hablamos de esto antes
podemos tener una cadena de adn
esta es una doble hélice si hiciéramos
un acercamiento aquí veríamos que
tenemos a las dos hélices unidas con sus
pares de bases algo así
esa línea verde es una doble hélice
ahora está doble hélice se enrolla
alrededor de unas proteínas llamadas
histonas por aquí se envuelve así y de
este lado se enrolla alrededor así y se
enrolla por aquí otra vez
y aquí están las histonas que son estas
proteínas
voy a escribir el nombre por aquí estos
son
is
tomás
el adn se enrolla más y más
alrededor de las proteínas y dependiendo
de la etapa de su vida en la que se
encuentra en la célula se forman
estructuras diferentes ahora esta
estructura cuando hablamos del adn en
combinación con estas proteínas que le
dan estructura estamos hablando
acerca de la cromatina entonces esta es
adn más
y proteínas estructurales
estructurales
que le dan al adn su forma cada vez que
he dibujado los núcleos de las células
hasta ahora he dibujado estas muy bien
definidas estructuras digamos que esto
es el núcleo de una célula aquí tenemos
un cromosoma y aquí podríamos tener otro
más corto y tienen su cromosoma homólogo
estos son cromosomas y cada uno de estos
cromosomas que son estas largas cadenas
de adn enrolladas sobre sí mismas si
hiciéramos un acercamiento veríamos esta
estructura que se envuelve alrededor de
sí misma de esta forma y luego aquí
tenemos a su cromosoma homólogo recuerda
que en el vídeo sobre variación hablamos
acerca de que el cromosoma homólogo
codifica los mismos genes pero tienen
versiones diferentes si el cromosoma
azul proviene del papá el rosa viene de
la mamá y ambos están codificando para
los mismos genes así que cuando hablamos
de esta cadena
digamos que recibí esta cadena de adn de
mi papá nos referimos a ella como un
cromosoma
pero no toma ahora bien el adn solo toma
esta forma en ciertas etapas de su vida
durante la división celular antes de que
la célula se divida el adn toma esta
forma bien definida durante la mayor
parte de la vida de una célula cuando el
adn está trabajando creando proteínas o
las proteínas están siendo transcritas y
traducidas a partir del adn el adn no
está todo enrollado de esta manera
porque si lo estuviera sería muy difícil
para la maquinaria podríamos decir de la
replicación y de la transcripción
acercarse al adn y crear las proteínas
permítanme volver a dibujar el núcleo
por acá
normalmente el adn no puede ser visto
con un microscopio de luz es tan delgado
que la hebra de adn está completamente
esparcida en el núcleo aquí está el otro
cromosoma
y tenemos estas dos hebras que son más
cortas por aquí
y no pueden ser vistas con un
microscopio simple no es una estructura
muy definida esta es la forma que
adoptan normalmente por lo que sólo se
puede ver este lío de adn y proteínas y
esto es la cromatina crowe
más
tina
todas estas palabras pueden ser algo
ambiguas y confusas pero el uso general
es cuando se está hablando de una cadena
de adn en este tipo de estructura bien
definida se está hablando de un
cromosoma el término cromatina puede
referirse a la estructura del cromosoma
la combinación de adn y las proteínas
que confieren la estructura o puede
referirse a este lío de cromosomas junto
con las proteínas todos mezclados juntos
ahora bien la siguiente palabra es
cromatina que es la cromatina cuando se
replica el adn así que vamos a decir que
este es mi adn como se encontraba antes
cuando está en su estado normal tengo un
cromosoma de mi papá
y un cromosoma de mi mamá ahora
supongamos que se replica así que el
cromosoma de mi papá al principio es
algo así es una cadena larga de adn
crea otra versión de sí misma que es
idéntica que se ve así
y al inicio están unidas una a la otra
en un punto llamado centro mero
ahora tengo dos cadenas que están unidas
aquí hay una cadena
y aquí está la otra cadena
ahora tengo dos copias que codifican
para el mismo adn y son idénticas esto
sigue siendo un cromosoma pero no
son más todo esto es un solo cromosoma
pero ahora cada copia individual se
llama cromatina
esta es una cromática
y esta es otra cromática también se les
llama cromáticas hermanas tal vez
deberían llamarlas cromáticas gemelas
porque tienen la misma información
genética por lo tanto este cromosoma
tiene dos cromáticas ahora antes de que
ocurriera la replicación o que el adn se
duplicará a sí mismo se podría decir que
este cromosoma justo aquí este cromosoma
del padre tiene una cromática se le
podría llamar una cromatina aunque ésta
no es la convención por lo general sólo
se empieza a hablar de cromáticas una
vez que se tienen dos de ellas en un
cromosoma y aprenderemos en mitosis y
meiosis que estas dos cromáticas
hermanas se separan y una vez que se
separan esa misma cadena de adn que una
vez se llamó cromatina ahora se llama
cromosoma
aquí tenemos uno
y aquí tenemos otro que tal vez se
separó en esta dirección
ese es el que había circulado con verde
y este es el que había circulado con
anaranjado
ahora una vez que se separan y que ya no
están conectados por el centro a mero
ahora lo que originalmente llamamos
cromosoma con dos cromáticas ahora nos
referimos a esto como dos cromosomas
independientes o podríamos decir que
ahora tenemos dos cromosomas
independientes cada uno conformado por
una cromática espero que esto te ayude a
entender un poco mejor la terminología
alrededor del adn siempre me pareció
bastante confuso todo esto pero es una
herramienta útil para cuando empecemos a
ver mitosis y meiosis y empezamos a
decir que los cromosomas se convierten
en cromáticas y que te digas espera cómo
fue que un cromosoma se convirtió en dos
cromosomas y como una cromática se
convirtió en un cromosoma ya que en
realidad todo esto gira en torno al
vocabulario quizá hubiera sido mejor
adoptar un vocabulario diferente en vez
de llamar a esto un cromosoma y también
llamar a cada uno de estos cromosomas
esa es la manera en que se ha decidido
nombrarlos
y en caso de que tengas curiosidad
acerca del origen del término cromo
cromo se refiere a color y proviene de
la palabra griega croma se le dio este
prefijo a los cromosomas porque hace
algún tiempo cuando la gente empezó a
explorar el núcleo de las células se
aplicaba un tinte a las muestras y los
cromosomas se tenían de modo que podían
verse claramente con un microscopio de
luz y soma viene del griego que
significa cuerpo por lo que se puede
traducir como un cuerpo teñido o un
cuerpo colorido por eso lo llaman
cromosoma en fin espero que toda esta
explicación te ayude a aclarar todos
estos términos cromatina cromosoma y
cromatina y ahora estamos bien
preparados para estudiar la mitosis y la
meiosis